hope you guys didn't see what I see
what'd you see look Evan it's bug likes
well why it's a fly okay
good morning good morning good morning
are we doing today I don't know the
first thing we're doing today we're
gonna go somewhat hiking ish my dad
wants to go exercise some exercise
you didn't come prepared for hiking dope
night visions were word I didn't bring
any closed toe shoes and now I regret it
you
I think any of them are good for hiking
they're gonna get dirty really like real
fast autumn look
I would get a neutral colored one and
well I guess that was a no-go on the
shoes we actually priced out from
faceless $2
it was like $100 plus for something
never going to just we're in Mexico so
how they know go
we're dizzy felt that mr. vogelin a
speedboat bike in America he always L so
right now we were trying to buy shoes
my dad said long we just gotta stop
London goes because according to my dad
the biggest market in Latin America
looking pretty much this place like big
made to me every single time I need
like so many turns so many stores and
it's crazy here
the morning everyone's opening they're
not gonna see how crazy creepy it is but
one quality stores open up like this is
like my kind of traveling I love coming
to places like this
when I travel I love getting in with
like the locals and I kind of getting to
see what their lifestyle is like and
this to me feels exactly that
I hate resorts resorts are too clean too
friendly I like dirty yeah uncomfortable
loud in-your-face something new it's not
a infomercial Wow
comfortable
you found it we're gonna grab a little
bit of food just like a little bit of
snack you have to go take home maybe
they'll say we're gonna grab a little
breakfast
today smells like oh my gosh our first
fight super bomb it's really clean it
doesn't taste like though I like June on
the card is it kind of crunchy
ha ha ha ha ha mister I'm sleeping all
right so the bucket that my dad is
driving around is breaking down he
usually goes through cars like he goes
through his underwear he's always
changing cars but anyways the car he has
now it's bailing on us like a little
loose no because of that reason we give
it away at my grandma's house so you can
try to fix it and maybe we might go
hiking still but doesn't look that way
anymore it's already noon I'm really
sleepy I just want taken
so we show that that I was for a while
his dad wasn't successful in fixing the
car so we're now going with her uncle so
yeah my dad had some business to attend
so we'll be seeing him later on today or
maybe even tomorrow we get to spend the
whole day with your netbook we're going
to a waterfall like if anything we could
see it from the road place where people
come and see it hmm all right so we've
really wanted to see this waterfall we
got out the car track down the highway a
little bit to get this but where we
could actually see the waterfall not
very close but it is it's gorgeous
though should move your feet there's a
lot there's a lot of red ants around
here and I'm trying to not get them on
my feet is actually a pretty bad spot I
know but we're trying to see the
waterfall so maybe at the waterfall it's
locked at least we got to see some
really cool bugs though along the way
yeah
you're okay Isaac you're okay note to
self if I ever wanna prank Isaac on his
birthday I know exactly what the
doctor's order is bug yep you're safe I
think you're safe you made it
except for butterflies so super hot my
head is all sweaty grab my head
can I
order yeah bathroom it came out
sorry
like it this just in my sources tell me
that you cannot find this dish anywhere
else outside of why the Lamar everybody
gets travel
Cerveny world welcome to dress
there's the uncle there is he the
stepdad and behind this is my mother and
for some unknown reason she turning into
a chair I don't know why
anyway right over is that those I was
explaining to you in history but I was
making sure it was in your bicycle
listen because I knew like if I would
stop and tell him like this and this and
this I mean yeah he'll probably retain
most of it but I know if I tell them
directly it's gonna go in when you're
not the others oh I'm actually curious
if you heard any of the histories I was
telling you I get I get what did you
learn from every remember that there was
an old guy I forgot one his name
but he was a guy that wanted to free the
Mexicans that were Slade spins right
that was from the Spaniard Spaniard
they were they were like slaving that
all the night
hey good job you learned that you
learned something
and sometimes I have to remind myself
that I'm not in Europe that I'm actually
in Mexico this place is gorgeous this
city is the beautiful city I mean I kind
of favor European architecture I think
by default of that I find while they are
like just amazingly beautiful I talk to
be very romantic I told you I told you I
told you I told you I had recorded thank
you for telling me so few months ago I
did like a DNA test if I know what
like where I come from they find out
that the majority of my blood comes from
Spain and Portugal area
history lessons hi uncle been giving us
today like it was pretty much solidifies
it I mean even though I already view
this but it's five years colonized
Mexico
it just solidifies that what I learned
from my DNA that's being that it's like
yeah my bloodline
now it's funny to leave this your DNA
pith and we just found out you're 100%
from China I am what you get don't get
anything more than this oh so hair
lighting looks good I like the sunset
it's my favorite time to shoot you know
what it's called when it's sunset it's a
good time to shoot Golden Hour
we've just been kind of Lilly dallying
for the past couple days because we're
saving the best for whenever my parents
get here and so we're just kind of
walking around wasting time last couple
days but it's been pretty fun though
it's been a lot of cultural experience
mister but wherever this is the macapá
feel without actually doing anything and
what do you know about that what did you
do to them I just tapped on his my like
yeah just no but you hear this sorry
Isaac
sorry